wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
billionaires think to get some success
advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one find your passion with oprah winfrey
i had a job until i could figure out
what it was really
what that gave my life its purpose and
meaning
and um i had gotten demoted in my job in
baltimore as an anchor woman because
as they hired me and then they decided i
was the wrong color
and i was the wrong size and i was the
wrong you know i had lots of problems
and they were trying to take me off the
air and um
i was making 22 000 a year i thought i
was in heaven because i was making my
age and my dream at the time was gail
and i used to say can you imagine if
you're 40 and you're making 40 000 would
that be it
so um
uh that was as big as my dream was just
to make my age
and then i did this they they put me on
a talk show one morning because um
they didn't know what to do with me
and and i was interviewing the carvel
ice cream man it was a local talk show
and
um
benny from um
benny who was miss
chancellors
uh butler or something on all my
children anyway my soap opera star who
wasn't the lead star remember benny
benny and the carville ice cream man
that's how i cut my teeth and i finished
that show so it's not about the the
the stars themselves or whoever the
guests were but i felt like this is what
i'm supposed to do
all these years have been misplaced in
news because i couldn't relate to news i
was a news reporter and i'd be out on
the stories and i'd be crying with the
people
and i felt that i was exploiting the
people with news i couldn't
you know put a microphone in people's
face when they were going through
tragedies and stuff i just was so
emotional i was always getting little
notes from my boss about cut that out
you need to stop so but the moment i did
that talk show i felt like oh
i can be myself
and that was uh august 14th 1978
and that was the beginning of fulfilling
the calling and so since that time
since that time august 14th 1978 i've
never had a problem with energy now when
i was working in news i used to be
exhausted all the time
i just exhausted all the time because i
hated it
and the reason i didn't quit is because
i'm not a quitter number one and because
my father was like better not quit that
job you're making twenty-two thousand
dollars a year
who's gonna play a black woman between
two thousand dollars a year you're never
gonna make make that kind of money again
you better save half of it so
i i was reluctant to quit and think
about doing something else because i
thought okay everybody wants to be an
anchor woman at the time that was like
supposedly a big deal being an anchor
woman so i thought okay i won't i'll
just stay with this until i can figure
out what is the best thing to do
and interestingly enough i was applying
for what i wanted to do
i felt like i needed to be able to talk
and at the time the only thing that was
available was um
was uh like good morning america or
today show so i called up this agent and
i asked if he would accept my tape
because i wanted to be like a substitute
for brian gumbel and he said to me
there was only going to be one bryant
gumbel and so there wasn't going to be
another one that they weren't going to
let another black person on that show he
said that to me
and um interestingly enough he called me
last week because somebody else mentions
it to say he never said it but he did
say it and i said to him you know what
if you're ever told that you never
forget it if somebody ever says to you
if you're ever rejected in that way you
never ever ever forget it i said but
it's okay
i did okay you did okay
it's all right but the answer to your
question is if you can find what is your
passion if you find what you love you
never get tired or if you do get tired
you're fueled by the energy of your work
so i know that i'm doing exactly what
i'm supposed to be doing at this time i
also know that what the show can do
in terms of being
a voice and changing the world it's just
the beginning of what this show can do
it's fun to do things like this
but uh and it's necessary to do things
like this in order to be able to do the
bigger grander things to change what
happens to to the face of children in
africa for example what happens to
education with kids in in this country
so i believe that um that what has
happened to me is really the beginning
of the greater passion to come
but if you find out what you're supposed
to do and you know what you're supposed
to do but how it feels
you know people wait on the voice of god
to be some the moses in burning bush i
think that was only bible talk
you know because he doesn't come to
burning bushes for people he comes
through your heart
he speaks through your heart through
your feelings and so you know what if
you're doing the right thing if it feels
like it's right to you and when you hit
the thing that feels right when you know
it's the right thing you would you know
it's right because it gives you your
juice
and you know it's right because you
would do it for nothing
you would do it for nothing and find a
way to be able just to do it
in order to be able to continue
that's how you know you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing rule number
two don't deviate from the path with
elon musk how do you
keep your focus on the big picture when
you're constantly faced with we could be
out of business in a month
well it's just a very small percentage
of mental energies on the on the big
picture like you know you know where
you're generally heading for
and and the actual path is going to be
some sort of zigzaggy thing in that
direction
um
and try not to deviate too far from the
path that that you want to be on but
you're going to have to do that to some
degree
but i don't want to i don't want to
diminish the i mean i think the product
the profit motive is is a is a good one
if the rules of an industry are properly
set up so there's nothing fundamentally
wrong with profit in fact profit just
means that people are paying you more
for
whatever you're doing then you're
spending to create it
that's a good thing
and if you're not if that's not the case
then you'll be out of business and
rightfully so
you're not adding enough value rule
number three weigh the situation with
jeff bezos sometimes
you know we we expand into new areas in
two ways um
one is
kind of you know
from
from a customer need we will work from a
customer need to the skills that we need
and the other one is skills forward from
a skill set we have to a new set of
customers so kindle is an example of a
customer need
and
you know so we don't have any hardware
skills
we've been doing this for 10 years now
but we'll go back and we'll go if you go
back in 10 years we had no hardware team
we had to hire somebody to lead our
hardware group and then build a hardware
team and build some institutional
competence at it and so on
that um that's a customer need backwards
approach and skills forward a great
example of that is amazon web services
we had the skills to do aws we had
probably more distributed computing
expertise than anybody else in the world
because of the transactions transaction
systems are so complicated and hard to
build and we had a service oriented
architecture of great complexity
probably before anybody else and so we
saw we could kind of because we were
doing that we could kind of see the
future a little bit
and
decided to build aws which has turned
into you know a huge uh business in its
own right
and
that is uh you know you if you were
always
business is very situational and so gen
rules of thumb are good but they have to
be applied to the right situation so
sometimes the old
maxim that you should stick to the
knitting is correct but sometimes the
adage that you should stick to the
knitting is wrong
and uh you know a senior leader's job is
to figure out in which situation are you
rule number four make contacts with
grant cardone success is a contact sport
you cannot be successful if you don't
make contact
you guys interview people and then you
never follow anybody up man nobody
follows anybody up
i spent i spent two million dollars with
a lawyer that's never called me back
same thing for the barber same thing for
the cosmetologist same thing for the
plumber same thing for the roofer dude
you guys don't call people back because
you think they're not interested do you
think i'm only going to have one car
accident people that have one car
accident end up in three of them
okay divorcees god gets a divorce
everybody here knows somebody's got four
of them
he ends up with four different attorneys
like you guys don't follow up you are a
business not a lawyer
the chiropractor has the same problem he
goes and spends all this money on
equipment he knows how to do an
adjustment he doesn't know how to build
a business
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out
where can people get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael he's got a new
book out build a serve go grab it today
at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five improve productivity with
bill gates i would say the most of the
opportunity to make computers improve
work is in front of us instead of behind
us
only at kind of a very mechanical level
of
it's better than whiteout
you know are we like oh wow this thing
helps me get my work done
for extremely structured tasks like
creating financial statements you know
where the application logic is very
opaque and you're just led through it or
for very horizontal things where you
really understand what you're up to and
the machine doesn't see
oh that email is part of personnel
review that email is part of
planning the uh the salesforce meeting
so we have kind of the the low-level
horizontal which in this way is
amazing and then we have this very
structured applications world
the idea of of
matching
what you and your head have is the
intention of the overall activity and
the semantics around it
and therefore sort of maximally helping
you with those things i think now
uh that a lot of base level things are
are done very well including gathering
the data and learning from it that we
should be able to
have what the machine thinks you're up
to and what you think you're up to match
each other
uh and
improve the productivity quality quality
quite dramatically but it's amazing it's
taken a long time to get to this
uh this point rule number six understand
technology with mark cuban there's
nothing that ai won't impact as big as
the so bit having been around a while i
saw the impact of pcs then i saw the
impact of low query networks then i saw
the impact of wide area networks then i
saw the impact of the internet then i
saw the impact of mobile then i saw the
impact of wireless you know now i'm
seeing the impact of of artificial
intelligence and it dwarfs any of those
things and if i don't understand how to
apply it to my businesses i mean i
remember selling pcs and software and
walking in saying you don't need to use
that pen and paper on on a you know on a
notepad or a ledger pad now we're going
to give you a spreadsheet and by the way
here's a here's a spreadsheet that costs
495 dollars and i had to pay to go get
trained on how to sell it which is crazy
now when you think about it but then we
said okay now you can play what if then
we said you can connect these pcs unless
i understood the technology how was i
going to explain it how was i going to
understand it unless i understand it now
how am i going to invest in it
you know then i got to go trust somebody
who says oh yeah i know ai and maybe
they do maybe they don't and it's really
easy just to have just to okay so you
figure it out that's just not my style
so you're building a base of knowledge
and then you think that at some point
it's going to pay dividends and trades
already has right i mean if they if you
truly believe ai is going to change
everything how are you going to
understand what people are doing to
change everything unless you at least
have a foundational understanding of it
now i'm not going to build a million
layer neural network and try to change
the world and i'm not going to show you
i'm not going to write a research paper
and saying here's how why the lottery
ticket approach works and you can build
smaller neural networks with less data
and be more you know
resource efficient but i can read that
stuff and understand that when somebody
says okay we're building this project
and we need this size data set or this
size data set we need this amount of
resources i can ask questions and
understand the answers and rule number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus clips is serve with jamie
curran lima the thing i think that i did
right from the beginning um and even
now in this moment uh now that my
circumstances are very different is i've
i've always known and this comes from i
think my faith deep down inside i've
always known that like what i'm called
to do isn't about me
and so
for me it's it's what's fueled me
in all the times
when it seemed like no one else believed
in me like i knew why i was doing this
um was so much bigger than myself and to
really shift culture and beauty
and even now
even just saying like oh my gosh
you started something in your living
room and someone paid you a billion
dollars for it like if i think about
that i can't even process it right
i can't even handle it because what
happens is i'll start thinking of like
oh but you know
i don't i didn't come from the right
family no one of my neither my parents
went to college all those things that we
tell ourselves about why
we're not the person that has those kind
of things happening to us um
and so so two things one i i often
remind myself that like anything that's
ever been created that's great or that's
a brand we all use now or a big business
like it was all created by somebody
really at the end of the day who's just
like you and me just like all of us
every single thing right so like why not
i'm not you why not yeah and then and
then the other thing is like when i
really start to um
kind of like get in my own head about it
because it is really
strange you see like oh yeah like
all those things like um
i i make it not about my i i know i
remind myself it's it's not about me
right so for my book for example i'm
donating 100 of the proceeds but like
like i the the book is to serve right
and like i i believe at the end of the
day that we get in life like what we
give you know what i mean along this
whole journey i've known it's bigger
than myself even now like i just i don't
know i believe that you know i'm called
to serve and and to
like i feel blessed to have accomplished
one of my biggest dreams but my my
biggest
my biggest driver now is helping other
women
um
and especially their entrepreneurs and
really other women like accomplish their
greatest dreams now i've got a special
bonus clip that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week when you watch a video and
just get motivated you have a 35 chance
of actually following through that's
what the science says and that is not
good enough believe nation we need to do
better when you actually get motivated
and then create a specific plan of
action for what you're going to do this
week you have a 91 chance of following
through and when you publicly commit to
somebody else like leaving a comment
below on this video it jumps even higher
so i want that for you i want to know
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and your plan of action for the
next week so i can celebrate with you
you don't need college learning learn
stuff okay
everything is available basically for
free
you can learn anything you want for free
it is not a question of learning
um
there is
a value that colleges have which is like
you know seeing whether somebody's
is can somebody work hard at something
including a bunch of
sort of annoying homework assignments
and still do their homework assignments
uh and and kind of soldier through and
get it done
you know that's
that's like the main value of college
and then also
you know if you if you probably want to
hang around with a bunch of people your
own age for a while instead of going
right into the workforce
um
so i think colleges are basically for
fun and to prove you can do your chores
but they're not for learning people ask
me why e-commerce so successful in china
our company alone is much bigger than
amazon
why e-commerce in china one of the
reasons why e-commerce in china is
success successful because china had a
terrible infrastructure of commerce
right we don't have so many retail we
don't have so many like walmart chema
everywhere
it's it's just a terrible
backward
retail system in china when internet
e-commerce come people love it so so
efficient
why china mobile phone you know grow
much faster than america america and
europe have such a great such a great
system of telephone we don't have ten of
them
right amount like 100 family can only
have one telephone that days when mobile
come we love that we just go that so
there is a leap flop
we don't have the rules or laws most of
the government offices they don't know
how to make rules laws for internet
because nobody realizes what the
internet look like so that leave us a
chance to grow fast
europe
very interesting you have such a perfect
rules loss
then everything you do let's follow the
rules a lot and everything we think
about the thing they do let's follow the
rules a lot and everything we think
about they start to worry when they
worry they make rules lost
when we have a problems we start to
solve the problems
then think about rules or loss
you have a problem that can make rules a
loss
so
i worry about europe
i worry
i worry about the worries of the europe
if every africa does not worry asia does
not worry why europe worry about
right you don't have solutions for
artificial intelligence oh you know
they're going to destroy a lot of things
human life
forget it
let me tell you artificial intelligence
i think
we alibaba using artificial intelligence
to arrest and catch a lot of thieves
my theory i told my engineers i said
now
when you love somebody you may not have
reasons
but when you
hate somebody
you have logic and reasons
we have logic and reasons machine can
always do better than that
so
we have a trillions of dollar
transactions on alipay every day
a lot of people want to steal the money
how can you oversee when you have like a
1 billion users using that there are so
many cheatings
human being cannot do it so we teach
machines to catch all the thieves
machines never forget
no matter how smart you are one person
can create 10 ways of cheating you are
the smartest person in the world
but we teach the machine
every way everything with this discover
from other people the machine can
remember over a hundred thousand ways of
cheating when you start cheating machine
find you
so
one way
bad guys using artificial intelligence
doing bad things other thing we're using
artificial intelligence to catch bad
guys
so there is always in a young balance
how you see the world if you see
technology revolution is a problem
i'm sorry to say the problem just
started
if you think it's an opportunity
the opportunity just started the only
thing is
your mentality
if the mentality is about a worry you'll
worry all the time
by the way
all the entrepreneurs
if everything's ready
everything's perfect
why they need you
because there is worries because there's
problems because of there's no this know
that that is your opportunity that is
our opportunity and
keep on that
you believing you can do something a
little by little ten years later you'll
be different that's that's that's who we
are when you first launched in the very
beginning the features were sort of
profile with like a profile photo in
your name and who you are and also you
included things like what house you
lived in um what dorm you lived in um
and what courses you were taking
do you think it would have worked
without that would it have been enough
just to have profiles
you know it's a really interesting
question and we certainly since then
have evolved and wanted to make a more
general service so we've sort of dropped
some of those things
but i remember there's this early
debate that dustin and i had where
we had to do some manual work for every
school that we that we released facebook
ad and um in order to do that we
basically went through and we parsed the
course catalogs of the schools to make
sure that the data was clean
and um and i remember having this debate
where dustin was like we could just
expand so much faster
or it would just be easier i mean we
were bound by server capacity but it
would be easier to launch new schools
if we didn't have to have course
catalogs for each school and we just had
this really long debate
about what quality meant for us and the
the community that we wanted to
establish and and the culture of it and
um you know in retrospect you know maybe
it wouldn't have had a huge difference
on on how things played out but it
definitely kind of set this tone where
there's a lot of kind of clean data on
facebook you can rely on it it feels
like a college specific thing yeah which
was valuable early on for setting the
culture even though obviously since then
we've grown beyond that and you know i
mean i think you guys in the projects
that you work on you're gonna have a lot
of similar questions right i mean
there's the famous 80 20 rule where you
know you get 80 of the benefit by doing
20 of the work uh but
you can't just 80 20 everything right i
mean there have to be certain things
that you just are the best at right and
that you go way further than anyone else
had to establish this kind of quality
bar and have your product be the best
thing that's out there so you know
whether we had to do that one or had to
do something we had to do i think enough
of those things or else we just wouldn't
have been the best service out there my
dad busted his ass i mean he worked six
six days a week um lit left at seven at
seven seven thirty in the morning got
back at six or seven o'clock
lost his eye in an accident doing
upholstery he had a staple break when he
was putting um
some
covering on a car seat
um
you know it was it was a middle-class
upbringing my mom did odd jobs
you know they they just wanted something
better i mean my grandparents came over
from russia and you know my dad was the
first generation my uncles were the
first generation americans like my mom
too and you know like every child of
immigrants they wanted better for their
kids you know it's funny i mean a lot of
people grow up that way right but not
many people end up like you so what do
you think that's the result of
i think
you know
everybody's got something that they're
good at and the hard part is just
finding it and i found out early that i
was a good salesperson that i really
liked business you know like i like
sports i mean i read everything i
possibly could played sports as much as
i could just wasn't as good as i wanted
to be and and business was the same way
i mean as long as i could remember i was
buying and selling baseball cards
garbage bags
whatever i could find stamps
to collectors
but i was also reading everything i
possibly could about business and you
know i was that unusual kid that i'd
rather read about ted turner than go to
the movies and and so i think that
created a foundation of my parents you
know my dad used to always say i don't
understand what you're doing
but i'm glad you're doing it and and so
i have my ups and downs along the way of
course but um i just think that i just i
just put in the time and was fortunate
enough to really get excited about
business and that paid off benefits over
the long haul turn your wounds
into wisdom
you will be wounded many times in your
life you'll make mistakes some people
will call them failures but i have
learned that failure is really god's way
of saying excuse me you're moving in the
wrong direction it's just an experience
just an experience
just an experience i remember being
taken off the air in baltimore being
told that i was no longer be being fit
for television and that i could not
anchor the news because i used to go out
on the stories and my own truth was
even though i'm not a weeper i would cry
for the people in the stories and uh
which really wasn't very effective as a
news reporter to be covering a fire
and uh crying because the people lost
their house
um
and it wasn't until they i was demoted
as a
on-air anchor woman and thrown into the
talk show arena to get rid of me that i
allowed my own truth to come through and
the first day i was on the air
doing my first talk show back in 1978 it
felt like breathing which is what your
true passion should feel like it should
be so natural to you
and so i took what had been a mistake
what had been perceived as a failure
with my career as an anchor woman in the
news business and turned it into a talk
show career that's done okay for me when
i was a kid glenn i was like
i knew i was going to do something great
and had zero
reason to believe that right
like it was a total fantasy
or maybe not
i think everybody has that i would
imagine that every kid
um
has this idea that they're they're
they're meant for greatness
i know i did i always thought i was
gonna be something great i remember my
twin brother uh he he would he'd be in
the mirror man he's like eight years old
we're eight years old he's singing in
the mirror like he's a rock star right i
had to listen to that all the time
and and then i started thinking man man
if he's gonna be a rock star
what he's to go on and be a big rock
star
and and and i can't you know
because i that that that wasn't my deal
i said what am i going to be
and then i thought i'm going to be a
baseball player
i actually believed i was going to be a
baseball player right dude i wasn't fast
enough i wasn't strong enough i didn't
have the arm i mean i had no talent
i didn't have the work ethic you know i
didn't have somebody pushing me so
i've just always underestimated what i
could do i think everybody does that
that's why this 10x thing that's why i
keep telling people man you're you're
thinking too small when i talk to people
about real estate don't do two units
got to start somewhere no you don't have
to start with two units
you could actually start with 32
right
and and by the way it's going to be a
lot easier to make money on 32 than it
is too sure
if if you can just believe that you can
you know and right now is a time where
people are going to have to start
believing they can do something else
because we're going to move into a
period of time now
where there's going to be massive
transition enforced transition on
everyone everyone thinks that spanx
actually started when i cut the feed out
of my pantyhose but the truth is it
started many many years before that it
started when i was selling fax machines
door-to-door
getting kicked out of office buildings
day in and day out and i woke up one
morning and i thought
i'm in the wrong movie
how did this happen this is not my life
cut scene call the director call the
producer no and i took out a piece of
paper and i wrote down what i was good
at
and there was not much on the page the
word i saw the word sales i knew i was
good in sales so i wrote down in my
journal
i want to invent a product that i can
sell to millions of people that will
make them feel good
and then i asked the universe for an
idea
and i waited for two years
and the idea showed up
and the minute i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose i decided to pursue it
so
what do you do when you have an idea and
you've never taken a business class or
worked in fashion or retail
i wanted to patent my idea
and i ended up looking for a female
patent attorney and i called the georgia
chamber of commerce
and they said there actually wasn't a
single female patent attorney in the
entire state of georgia
so i looked in the yellow pages and
found three men's name and went out and
pitched my idea to them and they
actually thought the idea was so bad
that one of the patent lawyers later
admitted to me he thought i'd been sent
by candid camera
which makes sense because he was looking
around the room for the hidden cameras
but he ended up eventually helping me i
went to barnes noble bought a book on
patents and trademarks wrote my own
patent
and went back to him and said please
please will you just write the claims
portion of it and he did for a
discounted price but it makes me think
about inventors and innovators and when
you hear those words do you think of
women
last year my son
had inventor week at his school and they
asked me to come and be the keynote
speaker at his kindergarten class
so
i was the uh inventor that was coming
and i started out looking at all these
cute little kids and i said so what does
an inventor look like
and all their hands shot up and one kid
said it's a man and he has crazy hair
and somebody else raised their hand and
said no no it's a bald man no it's a
tall man it's a short man and i just
stopped and i said
well i'm an inventor
and their eyes got really big and they
said you are
and it dawned on me i looked around the
room and all the pictures of inventors
were albert einstein thomas edison steve
jobs so i can see why the the young girl
who asked me and said i didn't know
girls could be inventors was surprised
and even my son on the way home he goes
mom you're an inventor
but the real point of all of this was i
wanted to help women and i'm so
passionate about it and it's amazing
that i started with their butts and i've
continued to groan i started at the
sarah blakely foundation because i truly
believe that the world would be a much
better place if the male and female
energy on the planet was more balanced
when you get to my age you will not
measure
how well you've done by how much money
you've got i can guarantee you that
you'll you'll all do fine on money
anyway i mean uh you know think about it
seven hours a day
you know
you're in a bed you've got exactly the
same mattress i've got if you don't
listen to it the furniture mark you know
i mean so so that when we're on a parody
i can't i can't outdo you you know in
terms of my sleeping enjoyment you can
you can match it by buying this mattress
which we'll give you a special price on
just mention my name
we eat at the same places you know we
eat a dairy queen particularly if you're
in my position because we own it but but
we eat at mcdonald's and burger king and
and when i leave here i'll stop by a
fast food place so our eating
experiences are the same
we travel the same i mean i had a 10
year old car until about a year ago you
know and it just doesn't make any
difference to me they they all work
we live in a place that's warm in the
winter and it's cool in the summer and
we watch the super bowl on big screen tv
you do it i do it you know we dress more
or less the same i mean i pay more for
my clothes but they look cheap when i
put them on so we're really
we're on a parody yeah so so the money
isn't going to be that big a deal
everybody in this country is going to
you know that with the intelligence this
group has the energy you have you're
going to do well
so what's the difference you know what
really counts
well i would say
that you will measure
health is enormously important and
that's a matter of a fair amount of luck
i mean you know so i won't i don't want
i'm not shortchanging it i'm just saying
you can't do too much about that but
you will measure your success in life
by whether by how many
and extent whether it's the people you
want
at 70 or whatever the age may be
you'll measure by how many of them
really love you you know in the end
i mean you can't
you know you you can't buy love i mean
it doesn't work you buy sex you buy
testimonial dinners you can buy your
name on buildings you can do all kinds
of things but the you know the only way
you get to be you know love is to be
lovable it's kind of irritating actually
you've got a lot of money be more fun to
just write out a check for a million
dollars
everybody you know from now on loves me
but it doesn't work that way and in fact
it the only way is to be is to be
lovable and you know i've got this
friend
who uh
who came out of auschwitz
and had at least one member of the
family die there
and
what is it now it's uh
60 years later
you know she still
when she looks at people it's a polish
jew
when she looks at people
the question she asks herself
in determining who she really trusts his
friends the one question in their mind
is would they hide me
now when you get to be 70
if you've got a lot of people that would
hide you
you've had a successful life
i know people who have a tremendous
amount of money no one would hide their
own kids wouldn't hide them i mean they
they really wouldn't i mean their
business associates wouldn't or anybody
else if it really came down to it
you know
they they don't have anybody's respect
they've got their attention maybe with
money or something that sort but they
they nobody loves them and
uh my friend tom murphy at campus cities
tv i mean dozens of people would hide
murph you know all kinds of people
would hide my wife you know
that uh ben graham a lot of people would
have my my dad it would have had a
number and then like i say that i can i
can tell you people
that uh you know everybody may pay
homage to them and the kids may put up
with them and hope they don't change
their will or something but the truth is
that nobody would hide them and if
you've got a lot of people that would
hide you
when you get to be 70
you will have a very successful life
sometimes
you know we we expand into new areas in
two ways um
one is
kind of you know
from
from a customer need we will work from a
customer need to the skills that we need
and the other one is skills forward from
a skill set we have to a new set of
customers so kindle is an example of a
customer need
and
you know so we don't have any hardware
skills
we've been doing this for 10 years now
but we'll go back and we'll go if you go
back in 10 years we had no hardware team
we had to hire somebody to lead our
hardware group and then build a hardware
team and build some institutional
competence at it and so on
that um that's a customer need backwards
approach and skills forward a great
example of that is amazon web services
we had the skills to do aws we had
probably more distributed computing
expertise than anybody else in the world
because of the transactions transaction
systems are so complicated and hard to
build and we had a service oriented
architecture of great complexity
probably before anybody else
and so we saw we could kind of because
we were doing that we could kind of see
the
future a little bit and
decided to build aws which has turned
into you know a huge uh business in its
own right
and
that is uh you know you if you were
always
business is very situational and so
rules of thumb are good but they have to
be applied to the right situation so
sometimes the old
maxim that you should stick to the
knitting is correct but sometimes the
adage that you should stick to the
knitting is wrong
and uh you know a senior leader's job is
to figure out in which situation are you
many times i've gone with what i thought
was fact and sometimes which i thought
were pretty good hunches and i didn't do
so well but i'm very fortunate that more
than 50 of the time i did do very very
well and i'm finding out more recently
in my life the last couple years that
you try not to just think with your
brain but think with your heart how do
you feel about the situation how do you
feel about the people no matter how kind
they are and i've had some really nice
people uh got in foreign countries and
everything else that were the nicest
people in the world turned out to be
total rip-offs but i didn't know that
there were clues along the way
so i say to everybody and i say to
myself now
feel the person out or feel the
situation with your heart what is your
instinct i think now more in life that i
go off instinct plus facts you obviously
have to have some facts along with it
does it become easier the more you do it
yep much easier when you're when you're
set to well how do i feel about this
shall we say with data stable data that
i have how do i feel about these facts
and then and how i feel about it just my
intuition how do i feel about it from my
heart yeah and the more you think about
doing it that way the more it happens
when you're down and out first thing
people do is blame it on everybody else
but themselves so true when you start
taking responsibility you have a little
different outlook you also have the
responsibility of turning things around
when i started paul mitchell i was
homeless once again totally by accident
and i started the company out of the
back seat of my car how old were you at
that time 30 seconds that was 34 35 at
that time so you're homeless at 34 35
again and what was this series of events
that led to that second time it was just
that we had money set up a half a
million bucks we needed to start the
company with that kind of money and uh
the day i was ready to start go down the
bank and get the money my partner the
hairdresser paul mitchell flew her from
hawaii with his girlfriend and we were
ready to get the money and get going and
get started i'd left everything i did my
relationship wasn't working out so left
the house plenty of money for many
months with her had a few hundred bucks
in my pocket took the used car which is
20 years old but a decent one okay down
the hill to get the money wow i was
going to check into an efficiency and
all set up
the money never came in no way nev the
guy changed his mind 1980 81 inflation
in the united states is 12 and a half
percent
interest rates if you could get a loan
prime rate
17
wow we stayed in line to get gasoline
and interest uh and unemployment was ten
and a half percent the united states the
guy said you're his hostages are still
in iran which they were at that time he
says is this a terrible i'm sorry it's
the last minute no
so it's a matter of what are we going to
do well in my 20s and 30s
i was fanatical about software
um you know i didn't believe in
vacations uh didn't believe in weekends
uh
you know i was focused on software uh
day and night you know i knew
everybody's license plate i knew when
they came into the parking lot when they
left
and i knew every line of code
[Music]
and it you know i enjoyed being a
fanatic uh
and you know i was really focused on
microsoft doing great software and you
know learning from our mistakes and
hiring the best
the best people is spanx started way
before i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose that's the sound bite in the
press that everybody's talked about for
almost 20 years but it actually started
fundamentally on
when i was 16 i worked on mindset for
myself and i'm such a believer in
mindset is almost everything
and it just happened to be a set of
circumstances i was riding my bike with
one of my best friends at 16 and she was
run over by a car and killed in front of
me
and then a few months later my dad left
home and my parents separated and
ultimately got divorced and when my dad
moved out he came into my bedroom and he
handed me a cassette tape series called
how to be a no limit person by wayne
dyer
and he said sweetie i wish i discovered
this when i was your age instead of the
age of 40. and then he moved out
and so i started listening to this how
to be a no limit person which was
talking about visualization law of
attraction
not caring about what other people think
about you the fear you know not being
consumed by the fear of failure and it
just the clouds parted for me and i
thought you know i've spent a lot of
time being taught what to think but no
one's really teaching me how to think
and at 16 that was so incredibly
important so in this digital platform
it's kind of passing on a lot of these
insights that deal with mindset that i
think is the real reason that spanx
exists i think you should be doing
something you're passionate about so the
question is always you know when i give
my younger self advice you know if would
i still go to stanford or this will go
to stanford law school
um possibly but i think a lot more about
why i was doing it was it is it just uh
you know and i was on this super tracked
for myself i ended up at a big law firm
in new york
in my eighth grade junior high school
yearbook one of my friends wrote and i
know you're gonna get into stanford in
four years i went to stanford four years
later went to stanford law school ended
up at a big law firm in uh in new york
where on the outside everybody wanted to
get in on the inside everybody wanted to
get out
when i left after uh seven months and
three days
um
one of the one of the people down the
hall from me said it was you know really
reassuring to see that it was possible
to escape from alcatraz which you know
all you had to do was really just go out
the front door but um but so much of um
our identity gets wrapped up in the
competitions we win
and um that um and when you compete
um and i think a lot of the
credentialing resume building is this
sort of competition when you compete you
do get better at what you're competing
at and if you take lots of sat test prep
classes you'll get a better score on the
um and when you compete you get better
at uh beating people on the narrow
things you need to beat them on but um
but you often it often comes at this
very high price of of losing sight of
what's uh what's truly valuable and
important and meaningful which is
well i think passion there's well
there's sort of all sorts of other there
all sorts of things that that could be
that but but i think
um i think it often
the the i think it often ends up being
uh something that's a little bit off the
beaten path because uh so i think um you
know there's there's obviously financial
version where you get to be have a
monopoly like business
there's a the meaningful version i think
is always counter factual where if you
weren't doing this
would you know it's great to be working
on problems where if you weren't working
on them nobody else would do them you
know if you're working at the fourth
online pet food company the 10th in film
solar panel company the 1000th
restaurant in philadelphia there's a
sense that if you weren't doing it
someone else would um you know if you're
working at uh
at something where
it's the only thing of its kind in the
world that's very meaningful if we
weren't if we and it could be for-profit
non-profit all sorts of context if we
weren't doing this this problem would
absolutely not be tackled i think that's
the kind of
that's what's that's what's meaningful
what's your main message on your heart
right now to people in this time
i would keep i would pay people
i would look at the things just like i
said about number one find out what and
who you need to cut
same thing i would tell a household what
and who do you need to cut from your
life
is there some obligation you have that
you don't need going forward cut it
yeah financial is there people in your
life that you could afford to have in
january and you can't afford to have
them anymore
you got to cut them you got to boss up
right now you got to be you got to do
the tough thing if you want to take care
of your tribe your group your family you
have to do
leadership is it requires tough
decisions
unpopular decisions the best advice i
can give somebody is do something that
you think is interesting
and let the waves catch you you know
something that i see people do which i
don't think is a is a good idea is they
try to chase the current thing i saw
this so much in 1997 and 1998 1999 with
respect to the internet there were you
know in 94 and 95 96 97
mostly the people who were you know the
kind of the earlier you get the more
true this is but you know the people who
were sort of looking at this space and
starting companies were genuinely
interested in it they thought it was
really cool
um by the time you got to 1999 like
doctors were stopping you know
screw that doctor thing
i'm going to start a dot-com company
you know and so um that really made no
sense whatsoever you know people were
sort of abandoning the things they were
genuinely interested in trying to catch
a wave and whenever you try to catch a
wave you're almost always too late
um
so it's it's better to just i mean if
you're paddling after it you basically
have to wait in place and let it come to
you we've got to try to create an
electric car company but it wasn't as
though in creating these companies that
we thought that we would be successful
i thought that the most likely outcome
was failure
but
but it was still worth doing even though
the odds of success were low in fact
even for for support spacex
the
originally what i started doing was not
creating a rocket company but but
actually was going to do
a small mission to mars which was just a
philanthropic mission where you would
send a small greenhouse with seeds and
dehydrated gel in the wood
upon landing hydrate the gel and you'd
have
this cool picture of green plants on a
red background and the public tends to
respond to precedence and superlatives
so this would be the first life on mars
furthest that life's ever traveled
um and you'd have this great money shot
of green plants on the red background so
um yeah i thought that would get
people's attention so
um
but but the expectation for that was was
no return one of the things that seal
said to me and it's in in the book and
one thing that people have said that
really resonated with them
he would say that when you're when your
mind is telling you you're done
you're really only forty percent
done
and he had a motto if it doesn't suck we
don't do it and that was his way
of every day
forcing us to get uncomfortable to
figure out what our baseline was and and
what our you know
what our comfort level was and just you
know turning it upside down
the 40 rule maybe it's give or take a
little but look at a marathon most
people hit the wall at a marathon at
mile
anywhere from 16 to 20
and you know
99 of the people in this country that
run marathons finish
and they all predominantly all of them
go through this hit the wall so where
does that extra 50 or 60 percent or
whatever the numbers come from i mean
it's their brain saying i'm done i don't
want to continue
but they're will saying you know what
let me get to the finish line the first
law is
the third law of motion in physics which
says for every action there's an equal
and opposite reaction and we showed that
very beautifully in the color purple
when messily says to mister everything
you even try to do to me is already done
to you
that is not just a rhetorical saying
that is law that is newton's third law
of motion
in physics which says everything that
goes out
is coming back it's just like everything
that goes up is coming down may take a
long time to come down is coming down
everything that goes out is coming back
it's coming back so
to answer the power of manifestation and
meditation what meditation does is sync
you up with the source
what meditation does is allows you to
literally tap into the power that
created you so that you are in alignment
with that
and so when you carry that out into the
world everything that you do
comes from the center of that alignment
that's coming from the source that we
call god we call divine energy divine
intelligence
whatever name you want to give it we
call life when you are synced up with
life
life just gives to you i think in order
to actually do the stuff yes money is
important but i also think the thing
that i hold the dearest and the reason
why uh
the noise about running for president
moved me so
uh
humbly and deeply is because it means
that you have somewhere in the work
gain the people's trust yes
and there is nothing more important to
me than having the trust of the people
and the audience and i i mean i
recognize that it is the audience who
came every day and watched you know from
all over the world that actually yes
that that helped me to be who i am so i
think the uh the the renowned the the
the standing the the ability to be
trusted and to say something but also my
listen don't play the billionaire thing
small don't play the be small yeah it's
it's a very big deal because it allows
you to
it allows you to
it allows you to actually do the work so
instead of saying gee i would like to
help so many people or you should go out
and help so many people you can actually
use that for yourself and i am now at
this stage of my career thinking about
how to do that
more poignantly and fruitfully i'm now
looking for ways that i can do that to
uh
create a level of sustainability in
within our communities it's been
a lot of fun
you know there's tons of things that i'm
not good at
and so the question is always can i get
somebody involved you know
you know certain day-to-day management
things negotiating things political
things
scientific experts who really do have
the time to focus in on one thing
like i did in in my 20s and just really
really see all the the possibilities do
you think there's a proven formula that
of a brand rookie guy he's got a lot of
ambitious gone out of this but not a lot
of knowledge and how to do you think if
he follows the formula he's guaranteed
to make it as an entrepreneur no no okay
so you don't believe there's a guarantee
to make it no because who knows who
you're gonna be competing with so if you
put two two people both following the
same formula both in the same industry
right which one wins you know maybe they
both can win and both be successful but
you know so i don't i don't think
there's a default default template for
success but i think there's things that
you can do to put yourself in the best
position to succeed you know so i talk
about stuff in the book you know i talk
about the one thing in business you can
control his effort you know um going out
there and sales curing all you know so i
i think you know and i agree with your
point that
there are things that if you do them you
put yourself in the best position to
succeed
but you know if you just walk into a
buzz you know a buzzsaw and somebody
else is doing them a little bit better
you know what happens do you remember
how much your first server cost you said
oh yeah no 85
dollars yeah and i remember that because
um that was the gating factor for us
launching new schools i i mean we had
this philosophy from the very beginning
that we didn't wanna be this project it
wasn't even a company at the very
beginning but we didn't wanna be burning
a lot of money right we weren't planning
on raising a lot of money we didn't want
to be one of these things that raised a
bunch of money and you know was losing a
bunch of money and then decided that
we'd somehow pull it through at the end
and
um so you know so
85 for the first server put ads on the
site and the the ads at the beginning
were uh we just were running some kind
of ad network and do you remember what
the first ad was
um
no i don't um
i don't know how did you get ads um
this was eduardo's job
was i mean with your ad sales yeah he
basically like he was responsible for
making sure that we had enough money to
keep things running in the beginning and
um
you know but basically i mean so it was
the server was 85
and you know dustin and i basically
worked on kind of efficiency and making
sure that we can fit more schools onto
each server
and
eduardo worked on selling more ads or
making a deal so we can get an ad
network so that way we can we can make
more money but then whenever we had more
money we rented another 85 a month
server and we kind of went from there
and um no just it's just an interesting
way of seeing you never spent money you
didn't have in the beginning not in the
beginning no and then i mean even that
was the constraint on your growth rate
how many new 85 dollars is you could get
yeah and i mean it was actually good
because i mean you know sometimes it's
really nice to have the time to
get your product to be awesome and deal
with scaling problems and one of the
things that was interesting was um
you know at the time i don't know how
many people remember this but friendster
was the service that had massive scaling
problems yeah you know the idea was they
were they grew quickly and it was really
hard for them to scale and um you know
the fact that we could kind of go
college by college and and kind of
optimize the service and make it more
efficient and offer new features but
make sure that they worked um i think
was really key i mean we're talking
about people who had never built a
company before we never built any
large-scale software
or anything so having that period where
we could just bake it um and you know
people these days like to talk about how
these services grow super quickly then
facebook did grow quickly but i think it
took a year for us to get a million
users and we thought that that was
incredibly fast but um and and i think
it is but
it wasn't as quick as a lot of things
grow today and i think actually having
that time to bake it was really valuable
the first three years of running this
business from my living room i couldn't
afford to pay myself and
literally hundreds of rejections i
thought ed oh i'm gonna shift culture
and beauty i have this great idea and
and you know so there's there's beauty
stores like sephora and ulta and qvc and
department stores every single one of
them said no
after no after no for three years
literally would say things like well
you're not the right fit uh
your packaging isn't isn't prestige
enough and women won't buy makeup from
women they don't aspire to look like and
it was just no after no after no
um for three years uh we got down to
under a thousand dollars in our bank
account by the way i'm sharing this
because when you google my story and
this is why i wrote this book ed because
if we don't share the real stuff like
that's when we feel alone in our own
rejection and our own you know uh
lack of success or traction right and
when you google my story
all you ever see is like oh yes denny's
waitress sold her company for a billion
dollars cash and it makes it seem like
oh she just got lucky or bruised yeah
yeah and
you know it was a journey
that didn't make sense to keep going
except for every time i would check in
with my gut i was like okay i'm supposed
to do this but everyone keeps saying no
um you know we got done under a thousand
dollars in our bank account as i
mentioned and
sometimes when there's no proof around
you that your idea is right and like
your friends and family are starting to
worry about you
and they're starting to be like are you
sure you should have you know started
this are you getting any sales yet and
it was like that and it was this this
three-year journey of having to figure
out how to turn down the volume
on my own self-doubt and
on rejection everywhere and kind of like
tune in or turn up the volume rather
than on that inner knowing that kept
telling me you're supposed to do this um
uh and that kind of was one of the
things that made all the difference
everything you do learn is cumulative i
mean that doesn't mean that
industries stay good forever or
businesses stay good forever but but
learning to think about business models
what i learned at 20 is useful to me now
what i learned at 25 is useful to me now
and so
it's not it's not so it's not a field
that
changes
dramatically in terms of the underlying
principles it's like physics i mean
there's underlying principles now
they're doing all kinds of things with
physics they weren't doing 50 years ago
but
but if you know the if you've got the
principles if you know what makes a good
business if you know what makes a good
manager you know if you know what makes
a a good product
uh
and you learn that in one business you
can there is some transference
to other businesses you go along and you
learn what things you you're not going
to understand i mean
knowing what to leave out is just as
important as knowing what to focus on
and
uh
i don't think i can win every game you
know somebody said how do you beat bobby
fischer you play him any game except
chess so i don't play bobby fischer
chess
and that's there's a lot of value to
learning that over time and and learning
what you're good at and what you're not
good at 1999 in my apartment 18 founders
the only purpose of that time we
survived
we 19 people we 18 people gather 50 000
us dollars
we think we can last for about 10 miles
and then raise money but only four
months later no matter how we tied the
budget we still run off the money
so everything we think about is to
survive but we believe
that internet will change china internet
will change the world we believe if we
don't succeed somebody will
but if we start to do now
and
be smart enough
finding right people do the right things
we will win
but later now uh that we're getting
bigger and bigger we now think it's our
responsibility
it's something that
it's amazing somebody put in our heart
that we should do more because we fund
we helped
created 40 million jobs we helped over
millions of companies small companies
survive why we cannot help a hundred
million jobs globally why we cannot help
small business africa middle east
developing countries developing
countries make them successful by the
way the difference between artificial
intelligence ai oh
and uh people is that machine never have
dreams we have dreams if you don't have
dreams you will never win with machines
in the future what do you say to
employees when
you have obviously have some traders in
the stock or not happy and suddenly the
stock is down 25 after a quarter
well i
so for well since 1997
at almost every all hands meeting we
have two all hands meetings a year
at almost every all hands meeting i
remind
employees
that you know if the stock is up 10 this
month don't feel 10 smarter
because when the stock is down 10 some
month you're going to have to feel 10
dumber and it's not going to feel as
good
and so it's you know ownership
is uh we give most of our compensation
uh
is is done in terms of
stock compensation
and
in part and parcel with ownership is a
mentality of of long-term thinking you
know you
owners think longer term than renters do
so i have a friend who rented his house
to some tenants and instead of getting a
christmas tree stand at christmas they
just nailed the christmas tree into the
hardwood floors
of the house no owner would ever do that
and um but sometimes
that's a bad tenant you know they're a
good good tenants but that's a bad
tenant and it's because you know this is
the same old thing about you know nobody
ever washed a rental car
and um
you you take better care of the things
that you own and and uh
but but one of the responsibilities of
ownership
and
definitely deep inside the amazon
culture is to think about the
fundamentals of the business and not the
daily fluctuations in the stock price
there's no information in it don't just
follow the trend so um you may have
heard me say
that it's good to think in terms of the
physics approach of first principles uh
which is
rather than reasoning by analogy you
boil things down to
the most fundamental truths you can
imagine and you reason up from there
and this is a good way to figure out if
if something really makes sense or if
it's just
what everybody else is doing
it's hard to think that way you can't
think think that way about everything it
takes a lot of effort
but if you're trying to do something new
it's the best way to think um and that
framework was developed by by physicists
to figure out counterintuitive things
like quantum mechanics so
it's really a powerful powerful method
is there any daily disciplines that you
have in your life daily routines that
you would attribute to your success
uh yeah i try to beat the sun up
i write my goals down every day
and i try to get i try to hit the gym
so i don't do it perfect every day sure
um some things throw me off and and um
you know unfortunately i have a i
created a lifestyle where where some
things are taking care for me that that
that um
most people don't have that that option
you know somebody drives the kids to
school i don't have to do that that
would change everything
if i had to do that who knows maybe i
need to maybe i need to start driving
the kids to school it seems like a
complete waste of time to me but
um i live two two minutes from my office
uh so when i bounce out of here i got to
go do a live a live stream on real
estate but but uh
yeah that that's the first three things
if i can get that done in the morning
man i know i'm gonna have a good day
yeah pretty simple to beat the sun up
make sure you write down your goals yeah
make sure you take care of yourself get
the blood flow and get the heart pumping
yeah and i goes down fresh a new unit
like in a new unit of time like i've
written down today like i had never
written them down before nice
yeah that's um so so so simple on the
outside but so many people won't do
so
i dare i dare everybody listening here
to try to do it for 30 days in a row see
if you can even make something you help
us understand how to cultivate how to
cultivate that um mindset of being
comfortable saying no being comfortable
delegating this is something that we
found with our members is especially
difficult for young women it's tough um
and we'd love to just hear your teeth on
that maybe any advice you have to share
about that i met bill goods
bill gates in 1991
and when i did it we had a great time
talking he thought he was going to hate
it and i i wasn't too keen on it either
and about 10 hours later we were still
talking but what really got him is when
i pulled out this little date book i'm
probably the only guy in the united
states with one of these still what
you've got
and i just flipped through it and you
know there's there's probably nothing in
it and bill was really impressed by that
and uh
you've got to keep control of your time
and and you won't keep control of your
time unless you can say no uh you
you can't let other people
set your agenda in life and of course
i know i'm in a very fortunate position
on that because i can i and in another
way i'm not so fortunate because more
people ask me for things
and and and then they're usually friends
and they say well can't you just make
this one talk or attend this one
graduation or whatever it may be uh
you know
you've gotta you just have to develop
the ability to say no and and and uh do
it a few times uh i mean you know the
woman can't say no she's in trouble
right
right and i mean is this something that
becomes easier over time or how did you
i don't think gets a lot easier no it
it's there's a couple there's a few
things that really just are
uncomfortable enough i've the thing i
like the the thing i dislike the most
the the only thing i really dislike in
connection with my job is if i have to
fire somebody i mean that does not get
easy for
the easier for me as life has gone along
and saying no is not like firing people
but it's got a little bit of the same
aspect to it it's not easy to say no
particularly to a friend uh but i will
have every day
three or four or five requests to do
something and i i can't do them all you
know and uh
but i'm not promising it gets easier
but but just keep doing it right
otherwise other people will be running
your life the process of me cutting the
feet out of my pantyhose while trying to
get the prototype made before i launched
it was two years so there was a year
solid of me driving in north carolina on
the weekends and at night or taking time
off from work to go and work on the
prototype get it made i learned so many
things that i didn't know as a consumer
it had never dawned on me you know that
men were making all of our undergarments
so i learned very quickly that the
industry had been taking an average
waistband size between a small
and an extra large and putting the same
waistband on every pair
exactly that's what i said i said you
know
that's not
working
we're really uncomfortable and they were
doing it to cut cost and production so i
immediately changed that in a spanx
waistband a size small gets a small
medium gets a medium and so on makes
perfect sense right
i also realized that they had been
putting a tiny rubber cord inside the
waistbands that had been there forever
well we had made so many advancements in
yarns that they no longer needed the
rubber cord but no one had stopped to
say do we still need to put this so i
immediately took the rubber cord out of
it and another thing i learned was the
way that they were doing sizing was just
so blew me away they would figure out a
size by putting them on plastic forms
and they would all put it on a plastic
form they had different size forms and
they would stand back with their
clipboards and go
yep that's a size medium
and i'd lean in and i go
ask her how she feels
so
at spanx we put our product on women my
mother my grandmother who's 90
my sister-in-law cassie i mean all of my
friends the girls at spanx we're testing
it on real women and we want to test it
more than two seconds to say yep that
looks like a medium we we have people
wear it for a week wash it tell us if it
rolled did it move did it stay in place
how did you feel very concerned with
spanx garments and how they made you
feel so what are your core values
personally and professionally
uh core values are i would say it's the
golden rule
do unto others as you would have others
do unto you that's the basis for most
religions but they get sometimes carried
away in rights and rituals but that's
the core value do unto others as you'd
have others do unto you and then it's
the feeling of knowing that success
unshared is definitely failure in other
words when you make it it's not really
just about yourself making it hey if you
make it you know you made it but along
the way one of the great lessons to
learn
is it's not all about you
it's about your ability to be of service
to this planet while you're here and by
saying me me me me look what i did this
is me hey here's my building my name's
on it you know i did this you didn't by
doing something like that it kind of
takes away
from how genuine you are and because
people don't like to just listen to
people talk about themselves how great
they are they want to know incorporate
it to make them successful also or do
something a little different and i think
that's very very important and i'm going
to tell you something that a lot of
people 99 of people disagree with me on
right everybody says follow your
passions
i say this
right i say follow your effort
it's amazing how we're all passionate
about things
we are all passionate about something
helping veterans helping this
organization helping this group that's
great
but
no matter what it all nets out to where
do you put your time
because when people put in their time
you get better at things and when you
get better at something and get good at
something then you have a chance to be
great at something and you know what
i've learned nobody ever quits anything
they're great at
and once you get great at it it's
amazing how passionate you become about
it
follow your efforts
right because it's not in the dreaming
it's in the doing a lot of startups
complain that they never get the money
from banks
never get money from the other venture
capitalists
well rejected by banks
rejected by your venture capital is very
normal you got money from these guys not
normal
why people want to help you
right
there's no reason people help you
you get help because
you earn the credit
you earn the repetition
so
borrow money
from your friends
families that's the sec first step as
everybody if you cannot even borrow
money from your friends and relatives
you guys have a problem
nobody trusts you
right
so i heard you borrow through two
thousand one thousand dollars that's
good that that means
you
have
this trust
from those people that around you at
least you got somebody to me
entrepreneurship
is about creating change
not just creating companies
and you know the most effective
entrepreneurs that who i've met
care deeply about some mission and some
change that they're trying to create and
often they don't even start because
they're trying to create a company right
and you know that's how i think about um
you know my connection to
to all of us here is you know i was
getting started i um and i wanted i care
deeply about giving everyone uh a voice
right and giving people the tools to
share everything that they cared about
and
uh bringing a community together and it
started small and in one university
and i didn't think it was going to be a
company at the time
as a matter of fact i was pretty
convinced that at some point someone
would build
something like this for the world but
you know i thought that would be some
other company that you know already had
thousands of engineers and was used to
building stuff for hundreds of millions
of people around the world and
you know what ended up happening was
um
you know that no one built it right so
we just kind of kept on going right i
mean people said it each step along the
way
um
you know what you're doing
all right maybe
college students like it but no one else
is gonna like it and you know there's
not gonna be any money in doing this so
all right so you only really do it if
you care right if you're passionate
about doing it and then it started
growing and people said it would be a
fad and it would never be a good
business but you know you keep going
because you care uh not because you're
you're trying to create a business
um
and
you know then there's the shift to
mobile where people thought that you
know it wouldn't be a sustainable
business and
um you know through each of these things
the entrepreneurs who i think build
things that last for a long time keep
going because they care fundamentally
about the change that they're trying to
create in the world
and they're not in it just to build a
company
[Music]
if you want another video on how
billionaires think check it out right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there we don't love this product but we
think others will love it you know
that's not really how it works if you
don't love it don't expect others will
either your relationship with time is
such a key component
of your life because